the dodgers technically come in three
games out of first place in the western
division san diego padres come in trying
to stay alive in the national league
wild card race
julio aureus who has been stellar all
season long 16-3 with a 3.11
era jesse those 16 wins lead all of
baseball and seven starts since the
all-star break a 184 era in his 27
starts this season the dodgers are 21
and 6. that is not everything you need
to know about julio urias but it's uh
sure a big part of the story he's seen
the padres twice so far this year most
recently august 24th that petco got the
win through five shutout innings
grisham leading it off for the padres
toting a 251 batting average grisham
strikes out swinging
and for julio aureus's
169th strikeout of the year he's walked
32 there's two out and will myers coming
up strikes out swinging and that will
end the inning
no runs one hit one walk one left joe
moss grove on the mound tonight for the
padres 28 year old making his 27th start
he's tossed a combined to combine nine
innings against the dodgers this season
two era opponents only 152 yes tatis
getting his first feel of dodger stadium
from right field anyway for the first
time in his career one out and max
muncie barrels this one up to deep right
center field back is tatis at the wall
he'll make the catch
little leap out there in front of the
wall but
makes the play i'm not sure he needed
the leap but
he did anyway and that's out number two
did not take a home run away but he went
up against the fence banged into it
gently and made the catch he turns
around and tells the fans two away
with two out first and second and chris
taylor coming up and his swing and a
foul tip held by nola that is strike
three and the end of the inning first
strikeout of the night for joel musgrove
and he earned it big time no runs no
hits a couple of walks and a couple of
guys left on base he's in first place
with two out he will continue fernando
tatis jr
one two swung on and missed right three
and that will end the inning no runs no
hits one man left after two and a half
padres nothing and the dodgers number
one out one on there's the first hit off
joe musgrove in this game belongs to
mookie betts here's max munson 19 home
runs at dodgers stadium 12 away from
here
swings and hammers one deep breath
maxwell swinging the silver hammer and
it's two nothing dodgers
home run number 32
nothing like home cooking for max munson
his 20th at dodger stadium and the
dodgers have a two to nothing lead
well he just missed hitting it out in
the first inning he didn't miss this one
the dodgers up two looking for more with
smith at third base there's taylor a
strikeout victim back in the second
inning with a 3-2 count and a high fly
ball to left gonna stay in the park for
will myers
tagging is will smith the catch is made
he's on his way home and he will score
easily
sacrifice fly from chris taylor and the
dodgers take a three to nothing lead
taylor's 72nd run bad at end of the year
that was textbook on how not to catch a
ball
for the runner tagging
no momentum coming in catch the ball
flat-footed catch the ball above your
hand with one hand and a three-nothing
dodger lead two down frazier at first
and here is manny machado there's a fly
ball to center field and deep taylor
going back he's at the wall and
[Music]
he makes the cash
oh what a play
by chris taylor no runs one hit one left
after four and a half it's the dodgers
three and uh padres nothing that's
junior this year against the dodgers
well he's hid for some power
looking frozen like a popsicle tatis
down on strike seventh strike out of the
game for aureus there's two out still a
three-nothing game a chance to add on
here in the sixth inning and lux was
brought back trying to help the dodgers
do just that thing
drop caught at first base by profar and
he throws the second and it goes all the
way into left field
seeger will hold at third smith goes to
second on the bad throw by profar
who had visions of a double play
not to be
luck's robbed of a hit but a throwing
error by profar gets seeger to third and
smith to second with two out
the bases will be loaded with two down
julio reyes the pitcher coming up here
in a bases loaded two-out situation and
a swing and a miss he struck him out
another curveball to uris and musgrove's
seventh strikeout of the night for julio
it's the first time he's pitched into
the seventh inning since the 21st of
july tommy pham is now going to pinch
hit for musgrove with two out and a high
fly ball into short right center field
bellinger cruising in makes the catch an
easy inning for urus who has shut out
the padres through seven another great
outing from julio lowering his era down
to 298 so now the dodgers have three
starters with eras under three ryan's
63rd appearance of the year in erf 186
opponents hitting a buck 70 against him
63 innings 73 strikeouts
got him looking
[Applause]
aggressive
watches strike three and there are
one out and the padres with two outs
have something going here they're
bringing the tying run to the plate all
of a sudden here comes will myers one
for two in his career against trying to
got him
that time no need for an appeal big
strikeout for blake trying to
andres leave two in scoring position
three outs to get for ken lee jansen in
his 60th appearance of the season
well he had plenty of rest before his
outing last night only nine pitches to
complete an inning but before that
outing he had five days off daughter
just needed to get him in the game
getting back on the mound he's had some
good workouts for those five days off
throwing a couple of pens and doing his
weights and his cardio
this big guy is on a roll right now you
look at that opponent's average at 163
deal one
here's a ground ball right to seeger
plays the hop
and that's your game
and a dodger w tonight in game one
against the padres three-nothing shutout
win max munster with a two-run homer
his
32nd of the year kenley jansen his 31st
save
and the dodgers get it done in the hand
julio urrias is majorly leading 17th win